por fin pueden abandonar el infierno de
los combates en Puerto Sudán este avión
estaba cuando a 71 refugiados a Qatar un
alivio para estos udaneses
en los últimos días es muy peligroso en
todas partes
todo el día
no sé cómo explicarlo
tendrías miedo y desgraciadamente ya no
hay seguridad aquí
[Música]
sufrimos los últimos tres días hasta que
llegamos a Puerto Sudán sin dormir sin
comer sin nada
antes en la otra dirección dos aviones
habían traído ayuda humanitaria de Qatar
20 toneladas de alimentos y material
médico una operación dirigida por Qatar
charity y la media luna roja catarí una
ayuda apreciada en un país donde un
tercio de la población ya vivía en la
indigencia un nuevo envío está en camino
está saliendo un tercer vuelo que
incluirá toneladas de suministros
médicos y alimentos que se entregarán a
los necesitados de Sudán
[Música]
la entrega fue posible gracias a las
negociaciones celebradas en seda entre
la ONU el ejército regular sudanés y los
paramilitares de fuerzas de apoyo rápido
desde que comenzaron los combates casi
500 mil sodaneses han huido ya del país
incluso a Egipto Chad y Sudán del sur